[Music]
you've heard of Christmas in July but
now I'd like to introduce you to
Halloween in April we've got creepy
rednecks dragons ghosts orcs and an
angry Luigi the most terrifying look of
all I can't promise every week will be
this spooky but I can guarantee that
hitting that subscribe button will keep
you up to date on all the hottest game
releases let's get to it out last two is
the follow-up to one of the best horror
games of the current generation this
time around husband and wife Blake and
Lin Lang our men are investigating a
murder in the middle of the Arizona
desert but it's not just cactuses and
sand out there the town is full of
creepy cultists and you can't fight back
your only option is to run and hide at
least you can light up the darker areas
by looking through your camcorder until
the batteries die that is man like just
can't catch a break anyway outlast two
creeps on to ps4 xbox one and pc on
tuesday april 25th the same day as
outlast Trinity which bundles the first
game it's whistleblower DLC and a sequel
you might not be able to really fight in
outlast to but the cast of Dragon Quest
heroes to have plenty of weapons at
their disposal like its predecessor this
is a dynasty warrior style game where
your party can take on hordes of classic
Dragon Quest bad guys like slimes and
candy cats but unlike the rest of the
warrior series this adventure has a
heavier RPG tilt letting you visit towns
and wander the map and if the fighting
gets too tiring on your own you can
always bring in some friends for four
player co-op Dragon Quest heroes two
hits ps4 and PC on April 25th as you can
probably guess puyo puyo tetris is a
combination of two puzzle games puyo
puyo and tetris must have been a pretty
easy pitch meeting our game has slimes
our game
has funny shapes you want to make people
play both at the same time sure you're
all familiar with the line clearing
gameplay of Tetris and puyo puyo is
pretty simple to match for slimes of the
same color and they clear out puyo puyo
tetris lets you play one or the other
swap between the two or play both games
on the same screen it gets pretty crazy
and you can enjoy that craziness with up
to four flattens and multiplayer it all
starts on ps4 and Nintendo switch on the
25th all right enough silly puzzles
let's get back to shooting people with
sniper ghost warrior three the third
game in the sniping series is the
biggest one yet and I mean that
literally because this one's going
open-world you can freely explore the
country of Georgia cross off your
targets and take on plenty of side
missions during a fictional Cold War it
should make for a great jumping on point
if you're new to the sniper games but of
course there's plenty of stealth and
tactics for veterans to your mission
starts on ps4 xbox one and pc on the
25th now let's talk about another fake
war because it doesn't get much bigger
than Warhammer 40k after more than six
years dawn of war 3 continues the real
time strategy series with more playable
Space Marines eldar and orcs and now
they come with giant Walker units
Marines get Imperial Knights the Eldar
get Wraith nights and the Oryx get
gorkha knots the battle begins on PC on
Thursday April 27 and for all you
warheads out there you can check out our
documentary on the game the day before
this is normally where I wrap things up
but one more important game is speeding
on to the track this week also I don't
want to anger Luigi Mario Kart 8 deluxe
takes everything from the original Wii U
game plus all its DLC and adds a bunch
of new stuff like King Boo and the
inkling zaz drivers but the biggest
addition is the expanded battle mode
letting you compete against your friends
the way God intended with balloon battle
coin runners and more you can take a lap
on Nintendo switch on Friday April 28
and those are the big games will be
playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with more new releases next week